♪ [intro music] ♪
Give me one minute,
and I'll show you how Workflows
can orchestrate and automate
your API-driven workflows.
Workflows is a fully managed service
that gives you the power to integrate
tasks, microservices, and APIs.
Reliable execution lets you create
dependable workflows
that can automate complex processes
across any Google Cloud products
or HTTP-based APIs.
Since it's fully serverless,
you can focus on the logic
and not worry about the infrastructure
or how to scale.
Built-in error handling and retry policies
give you a highly reliable
and resilient architecture.
Dashboards give you true visibility
into what's happening and when.
Getting started is easy.
Using the console or the command line,
you can define your workflow
as a simple YAML or JSON file
to spell out which services
and APIs you want to include.
Each service can also pass
information to the next,
letting you build custom workflows
that match the business logic you need.
And since it's all serverless,
you only pay for what you need,
scaling down to zero during slow times.
Let's look at an example use case.
Maybe you have a website
called BeyondTree,
a one-stop shop for vegan dog treats.
You might decide to create a workflow
to fulfill orders for specific dog treats.
A new order kicks off the workflow.
First, we check Cloud Firestore
to see if we have enough inventory.
If we do, we update
the inventory in the database.
Then, a Cloud Run app fulfills the request
and calls a third-party email API
to send the customer
an order confirmation.
If there isn't inventory,
the workflow can check once per day
until the item is back in stock.
So next time you're looking
to automate your application services,
take a minute to look at Workflows.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/workflows